FROM THE WHITE HOUSE, JEN PSAKI
HAS THAT.
WATCH.
>> I WOULD SAY IT’S CLEAR WE
NEED TO WORK MORE ON GETTING
THE MESSAGE OUT AND BEING VERY
CLEAR NOW IS NOT THE TIME TO
COME.
THERE IS THE MAJORITY OF PEOPLE
WHO COME TO THE BORDER ARE
TURNED AWAY.
>> Dana: JEN PSAKI ADDRESSING
THE ESCALATING CRISIS ALONG THE
SOUTHERN BORDER AS THEY’RE
SURPASSING THE NUMBER OF
DETENTIONS LAST YEAR AFTER THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATIONS
DRAMATICALLY DECREASED ILLEGAL
IMMIGRATION IN ITS FINAL YEAR.
MARK MORGAN.
I’M REMINDED THERE WERE TIMES
WHEN AT A WHITE HOUSE YOU WANT
TO TALK ABOUT YOUR EDUCATION
PROPOSAL BUT SOMETHING ELSE
KEEPS GETTING IN THE WAY.
I SENSE A LITTLE FRUSTRATION
FROM THE WHITE HOUSE THAT THEY
KEEP BEING ASKED ABOUT
IMMIGRATION WHEN THEY WOULD
MUCH RATHER TALK ABOUT COVID.
>> DANA, THIS IS WHAT THEY GET.
I THINK THE PRESIDENT TRUMP
SAID IT BEST DURING THE CPAC
SPEECH.
THIS IS A SELF-INFLICTED WOUND
THEY BROUGHT ON THEMSELVES.
THE NUMBERS, FEBRUARY NUMBERS.
WE’LL LOOK AT OVER 100,000
INDIVIDUALS THAT ILLEGALLY
ENTERED IN THE MONTH OF
FEBRUARY.
AND THE FORMER SECRETARY JAY
JOHNSON WHEN HE WAS REFERRING
TO 1,000, HE WAS TALKING TO
ABOUT 1 THOUSAND APPREHENSIONS
PER DAY.
TRUST ME IF WE HAD OVER 1,000
APPREHENSIONS IN A SINGLE DAY
WAS A BAD DAY.
WE ARE LOOKING NOW GETTING
CLOSE TO 5,000 APPREHENSIONS A
DAY AND STILL REFUSE TO SAY
IT’S A CRISIS.
SINCE JANUARY DANA THEY’VE
RELEASED OVER 11,000 ILLEGAL
ALIENS AT BUS STATIONS AND
SHELTERS LOCALLY AND THEY’RE
BUSING THEM FURTHER INTO THE
UNITED STATES AND REFUSE TO SAY
IT’S A CRISIS.
>> Bill: DID YOU SEE "THE NEW
YORK TIMES." THEY CALLED THESE
FACILITIES JAIL-LIKE
FACILITIES, DID YOU CATCH THAT?
AND DID YOU THINK ABOUT THE
DISTINCTION WITH ALL THE HEAT
THAT CAME ON THE TRUMP TEAM FOR
THE CAGES COMMENTS?
>> YEAH, BILL.
THE HYPOCRISY.
LEVEL AFTER LEVEL OF HYPOCRISY.
UNDER TRUMP THESE SAME
FACILITIES, I WAS THERE, THE
SAME FACILITIES WERE INHUMANE
AND IMMORAL.
NOW FACILITIES ARE BEING BUILT
BY THE SAME VENDORS ARE SOMEHOW
ESSENTIAL AND HUMANE.
HYPOCRISY.
WHAT’S MORE IMPORTANT IS HOW
THEY ARE USING THE FACILITIES.
HE DISMANTLED EVERY EFFECTIVE
TOOL AND REPLACED IT WITH
NOTHING.
NOW WHAT THEY ARE DOING ON THE
BORDERS, THESE FACILITIES ARE
USING THEM AS RECEPTION CENTERS.
THE MANDATE HAS BEEN TO RELEASE
AND PROCESS THEM AS FAST AS
POSSIBLE.
ON THE BACK END PREVENTING ICE
FROM DEPORTING THEM.
RECEPTION CENTERS ON THE FRONT
END, SANCTUARY COUNTRY ON THE
BACK END.
THAT’S WHERE WE’RE AT RIGHT NOW.
>> Dana: WHAT DO YOU HEAR FROM
THE PEOPLE THAT WORKED UNDER
YOU TRYING TO PROCESS?
I’M TRYING TO GET MY HEAD
AROUND HOW DO YOU DEAL WITH
5,000 APPREHENSIONS A DAY
PHYSICALLY?
>> IT’S TOUGH.
LOOK, I THINK WE’RE ONE OF THE
MOST POWERFUL NATIONS IN THE
WORLD AND WE CANNOT DEAL WITH
100,000 ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS
ENTERING OUR BORDER EVERY MONTH.
5,000 A DAY.
RIGHT NOW AT ONE POINT IN 2020
WE HAD LESS THAN 500 PEOPLE IN
OUR CUSTODY BECAUSE OF THE
TRUMP POLICY.
RIGHT NOW DANA THEY HAVE OVER
6,000 IN CUSTODY IN THE MIDDLE
OF A GLOBAL PANDEMIC.
LIKE YOU SAID, HALF OF THOSE,
OVER 3,000 ARE UNACCOMPANIED
KIDS BECAUSE THE SYSTEM IS
ALREADY OVERWHELMED.
HHS DOESN’T HAVE THE FACILITIES.
WE HAVE OH HE BEEN HERE BEFORE
AND EXPERIENCED THIS IN 2019.
WE TOLD THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION IF THEY DID WHAT
THEY’RE DOING THIS IS WHAT
WOULD HAPPEN.
THEY IGNORED US.
THIS IS WHAT THEY WANTED TO DO.
>> Bill: WE NEED TO WORK MORE
GETTING THE MESSAGE OUT NOW IS
NOT THE TIME TO COME.
HOW DO YOU LESSEN THE FLOW NOW,
SIR?
>> YOU DON’T.
THEIR MESSAGE -- BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION HAS BEEN CRYSTAL
CLEAR.
THEIR MESSAGE IS OUR BORDERS
ARE OPEN AND COME ON IN.
WHEN YOU DO WE’LL RELEASE YOU
INTO THE UNITED STATES AND THEN
NOT DEPORT YOU LAWFULLY SO YOU
CAN REMAIN HERE ILLEGALLY
FOREVER.
TO TELL THE SMUGGLERS AND
CARTELS AND MIGRANTS THEMSELVES
PRETTY PLEASE DON’T COMET IS A